so alec baldwin was filming his new
movie rust when there was an issue with
a fake prop gun on set that he shot and
then incidentally killed the head
the i believe she's director of
photography
as and then it also she's the woman
who's behind the camera yeah and it also
so you know the new ahead of uh thick
boy creative mike neal he the last movie
he did she was the same so he's he was
really close with it so i met with him
on thursday i didn't realize what's
going on he was not doing my friend did
my friend did four movies not doing well
yeah terrible you know um uh i've done a
lot of stuff with guns on movies not a
lot but enough and uh
it the
first of all it's such a
controlled atmosphere when it's supposed
to be right when you have an armor i've
never heard of a 24 year old armor i've
never heard of that that there are
always
usually men in their 50s and 60s who've
been around a long time apparently what
happened was her body was they're not
the uh she wasn't the original armor
there was a production team that was
involved with all that they actually had
a walkout because they were complaining
about the work hours there were there
was a strike and they released everyone
last
minute and she became the head armorer
that way and i think her dad is her
second drummer i think her dad's uh her
dad's a famous he died so she's grown up
around guns but i asked mike who knows
her well who passed away and he's saying
one of the problems is and he i guess he
spoke to her previously is the the
budget for it they're trying to stretch
the budget so thin he's like they just
have the the protocols in place like
they cut where they could all over and
then this type of [ __ ] happens well
first of all also you got the first ad
you've got the uh you've got the armor
you've got the stunt coordinator there's
so many people that are supposed to be
here watching this now
i heard they were using a real gun which
is crazy but these old sick shooters if
you have if you have the camera you want
to see the uh you want to see the
bullets sort of you know in the in the
shot i don't know what the [ __ ] a real
gun was doing there i don't know
how they were shooting it at the camera
none of that makes sense but my guess is
she was behind the lens trying to
capture a shot
and
and
uh alec ball was given the gun and he
was told to shoot at camera first of all
when you do that you usually lock camera
off and you [ __ ] step away from
camera and there's a screen that's
always and so also so when you're
shooting blanks also what happens is
whenever you shoot a blank you always
lock camera off and step away why
because when you shoot sometimes a piece
of the shell that is actually holding
the the gunpowder and stuff the piece of
the shell can break off so you can have
fragments of metal without even knowing
it in the barrel
that's why you
no matter what you never ever shoot it
at somebody who's actually there
standing there so it's the whole thing
makes no sense to me i don't understand
how it happened i don't know
he was given uh she was given or he was
given a live
a real gun i think that's what happened
i think it was a real gun i think you
had a real bullet in it it was a real
bullet though it was real crazy i i
thought at first it was exactly what
happens which is you got it with blanks
and there was a piece of the shelling in
there
because they used the shells over and
over i guess what mike was telling me is
because they're out in the middle of
nowhere the production team and p and
actors
to have fun between sets which like go
out and shoot real guns that's right
so
another okay so that's another thing
terrible i have never heard of
ever having real guns on a set you never
do that like my generation of movie like
from where i'm from you'd never ever
have that if you had a real gun on set
even a real gun that didn't have bullets
it'd be no [ __ ] she had a 12 year old
kid too man
terrible yeah it's a terrible horrible
it's tragic forever yeah it for
including obviously the the worst for
her and her family yeah but also
terrible for i know everyone wants to
say it's terrible for al baldwin man he
must be so traumatized
and it's not his fault oh they said he
is [ __ ] up of course he is and the uh
victim's father actually also came out
to alex defense because a lot of people
were calling him a murderer initially
when it came out
and so he's saying like it's not alec
baldwin's fault at all he's not the
reason why my daughter is gone it's
because production didn't do their job
yeah right
look it's a disaster yeah all the way
around just so tragic man but i'm also
like i'm so amazed it happened
it's so crazy like there's supposed to
be so many checks and balances on my my
friend's uh stuntman was just working on
that particular set you know and he was
just like it's the craziest [ __ ] not on
that movie they were sharing the set but
he was like it's just the craziest thing
i've ever heard i've never heard of
anything well they said you know when
brandon lee died the way that happened
so you you put in like a fake bullet but
also what happens they didn't know
there's already something i guess in
there or casing so that was the case
they put in the other another fake
bullet well when you do that
that fake casing turns into a bullet
because it's a hard piece of metal so
it'd be just like you're firing a real
bullet yeah apparently they wanted to
get the shot with the boat you see you
could see the bullets in it yeah and
that bullet was in there with the the
fake casing was in the back already
someone reloaded it so that's how he
died it goes right into your body just
right into you but this must have gone
right into her eye no chest it went into
her oh i'm sorry
it was either chester uh stomach i'm
sorry chest because it went through her
chest
and then hit the director on her
shoulder
oh [ __ ] you're talking about a real slug
like a real bullet terrible [ __ ]
tragedy
i mean tragic
horrible i mean you're right though
because well brian you're saying like
how how
why is the assistant whatever
cinematographer or whatever she is and
the director why are they being
the gun point at them yeah like both of
them the camera should have been locked
off but also so i i don't understand
that that i'm already confused about
that second of all the other thing i'm
confused about is what the [ __ ] was a
real gun doing exactly yeah using a real
bullet and when they're using six
shooters a lot of times people get
geeked out and they want to you they
want to you they want to have
authenticity
again i've never heard of that i don't
know anybody who's a real armorer that's
tragic very charging her dad
mike was saying what mike was saying who
has a lot of expensive moves he goes
also what they're trying i know what
they're trying to do they want the real
effect from the gun as it's coming out
he goes but even like that time of the
day the set was lit like you can do that
in post like what they're going for so
[ __ ] he was like it makes no sense
all the way around like what they're
trying to go with the actual gunfire and
they come out of the gun he's like you
can do that in post because so there's
no reason she should have died yeah or
there should have been a real gun yeah
maybe they were trying to slow the
camera down way down have a real
horrible